sono passati ormai quasi 50 anni da
quando mia mamma mi fece vedere
un'immagine molto spettacolare questa
qua e mi disse questo è un vulcano è una
montagna che sputa fuoco e sputa anche
una sorta di pietra che così calida che
è fusa che liquida si chiama lava
evidentemente questa cosa mi ha fatto
una certa impressione perché qualche
annetto dopo mi sono messo a dipingere
per la prima volta un vulcano in piena
eruzione
così come un bambino disegna un vulcano
con la lava che scorre giu i fianchi
esagerare esageratamente ripidi di
questo vulcano poi passarono ancora
altri anni e ho cominciato a veramente
affascinarmi di vulcani e quindi a
seguirvi attraverso i media dell'epoca
stiamo sempre parlando di più di 40 anni
fa e quindi erano giornali era la radio
era la televisione nero e bianco e fra
tutti questi vulcani di cui ogni tanto
si parlava perché entrarono in eruzione
facevano parlare di sé ogni anno almeno
una due volte si parlava di un vulcano
particolare quindi è molto attivo fra i
più attivi al mondo e quindi questo l'ho
cominciato a seguire in particolare è
cominciato anche a sognare di questo
puntano di visitarlo scoprirlo forse un
giorno anche di viverci
perché allora ero ancora in germania
dove sono nato dove poi mi sono messo a
studiare scienze della terra geologia
per perché avevo questo sogno di
diventare un vulcanologo e poi di andare
a vivere
ecco su questo vulcano particolare
eccezionale dove adesso effettivamente
ci vivo ci lavoro e potete immaginare
c'è la quale vulcano sia giusto e la
nostra signora molto molto focosa l'etna
vulcano veramente straordinario
eccezionale che ha sin dall'inizio della
storia dell'umanità in convivenza con
questo vulcano affascinato fa il fatto
impressione è che ci ha vissuto anche
gli antichi greci per esempio che
consideravano l'etna la dimora del loro
dio del fuoco e files tos che poi fu
adottato dai romani per diventare
vulcanus vulcano
come ho detto straordinario un vulcano
che cambia che si reinventa quasi in
continuazione
se avessimo a disposizione un mezzo di
trasporto molto particolare che sarebbe
la macchina del tempo e questa ci
potesse portare indietro fino all'anno
fino all'inizio del secolo scorso e
potessimo guardare dall alto verso la
vetta di questo vulcano è questo che
vedremo un singolo grande cratere
sommitale dell'eta e cratere centrale
che già esisteva da molti secoli
però poi sembra che a questa signora
focosa non ci fosse più bastato un solo
cratere sommitale così ha fatto in modo
che ci fosse una sorta di proliferazione
i crateri sommitali e quasi oggi ne
contiamo non meno di quattro i crateri
nord est quello più alto la voragine la
bocca nuova
i crateri di suter anzi dovremmo dire
quattro e mezzo perché negli ultimi
cinque anni si è aggiunto il fratello
del cratere sud est e con tutta la
nostra immaginazione fantasia
abbiamo voluto chiamare il nuovo cratere
di sud est
che poi in questi ultimi anni penso che
molti di voi
molti di noi l'abbiamo visto a volte ha
destato un po di preoccupazioni ed
eccolo qui il figlio più giovane della
grande mamma etna che sta facendo questa
cosa che spesso ispira la gente di qua a
dire a oggi l'età sto fumando molto più
del solito
l'etna fuma no non fu
perché quello che fa fumo è roba
combustibile che brucia questo in un
vulcano non succede nei sull'etna né su
qualsiasi altro vulcano sulla terra
invece quello che vediamo sempre uscire
dall'etna soprattutto quando c'è poco
vento e questo si alza nell'aria e nell
altro che gas sono diverse specie tra
cui anche alcune molto sgradevoli e poi
quella più abbondando in assoluto
vivamente un gas che conosciamo dalla
vita quotidiana lo conosciamo molto bene
vapore acqueo vapore acqueo che viene
dall'interno della terra ed esce da
letta in quantità veramente
impressionanti dovete immaginare che
ogni singolo giorno tal etna viene
emessa la bellezza di un milione di
tonnellate di vapore acqua almeno un
milione che corrisponde a circa un
miliardo di litri di acqua è che fa
questo vapore acqueo vapore acqua e si
comporta un pochettino come un altro gas
che conosciamo molto bene lo conosciamo
per esempio nelle nostre bibite
frizzanti che sarebbe da co2 l'anidride
carbonica possiamo immaginare per
esempio una bottiglia di spumante
quando chiuse a questo caso non lo
vediamo perché disciolto nel fluido
quando invece si decomprime questo
ambiente stappando una bottiglia il gas
si libera si separi dal fluido e forma
bollicine che crescono molto rapidamente
nel caso del vapore acqueo quando questo
succede
aumenta di volume di 17 mila volte il
che è un processo molto esplosivo
soprattutto quando non si tratta di
spumante ma invece di roccia fusa
anatema quindi questo magma viene
trasformato in schiuma questa schiuma
viene strappata miriadi i pezzettini di
roccia vulcanica che poi vengono
lanciati in eruzioni esplosive
nell'atmosfera formando questi
impressionanti pennati come quelli che
abbiamo visto poco tempo fa all'inizio
di dicembre 2015
e questi frammenti richiamiamo quando
sono piccoli come grande di di sapere
che amano cenere vulcanica
quando sono pezzettini di qualche
centimetro parliamo di lapilli tutto
quello che più grande dice
sei centimetri e mezzo e chiamiamo bombe
vulcaniche anche se questo non esplodono
e quindi questo materiale viene lanciato
nel cielo e forma genericamente quello
che chiamiamo terra o materiale
piroclastico e quando c'è molto molto
accendere molto materiale fine in questi
pennac in queste colonne e routine si
possono anche formare come ultimamente
osservato degli spettacoli delle
spettacolari scariche elettriche dei
fulmini lampi questo materiale quindi
venne lanciato anche fino a molti
chilometri di altezza e poi ricade sul
nostro territorio cade su tutto copre
tutto con uno strato di detrito
vulcanico nero copre strade case balconi
terrazzi terreni e causa problemi per
esempio rende le strade molto scivoloso
come quasi come se fosse neve solo che
questa dire nera e non si scioglie e
però invece bisogna iniziare e poi
cominciano già i problemi perché qua
alla grande passione è proprio quella di
fare pulizia fuori da casa nostra no
però se no il problema è che è con sé
stanti scivoloso sei metri scivolose se
invece questo materiale non si toglie ci
passano sopra tante tante tante macchine
questo materiale viene frantumato sempre
di più e diventa man mano polvere molto
sottile che poi si alza nell'aria e
riduce la visibilità che per chi si
trova sulla strada e poi viene anche
respirato da chi ci si trova dentro si
sé né traffico sia la gente che ci vive
e ma possono cominciare ad esserci
veramente problemi seri anche per la
salute e quindi ci conviene di fare
eccezione di superare noi stessi e
cominciare a fare vendere veramente
pulizia e le rare questa roba qua perché
non deve restare sulle strade non deve
restare sulle nostre case deve essere
assolutamente elevata e fa c'è anche un
interesse proprio personale soprattutto
per gli autisti siciliani che limiti di
velocità di dieci chilometri all'ora è
un'offesa nota in un autista siciliana
quindi non può andare così
e poi si possono anche fare cose
interessanti teoricamente e abbiamo già
visto ci sono certe ditte per esempio
una titta new age che ha messo in
vendita on line
questa saponetta levigante con la cenere
vulcanica dell'etna perpretare caldi
fanno anche delle cremine per il peeling
è stato anche proposto di utilizzare
questo materiale piroclastico di
ricaduta come materiale di costruzione
così semplici non è perché per esempio
in questo momento questo materiale
ancora dichiarato rifiuti speciali che
richiede una procedura estremamente
complicata costosa non molte imprese
sono specializzate in questo è quindi un
problema che resterà con noi per un po
anche perché l'etna sembra in questo
periodo molto decisa di andare avanti
con questo tipo di attività molto
esplosiva e quindi avremo ancora a che
fare con questi problemi penso durante
la nostra vita e quindi dobbiamo
inventarci soluzioni nonostante per
essere in tema
nonostante questi problemi però l'etna
magari ci vuole anche dare certi
messaggi e per esempio guardare suolo
intorno a noi vedere come per esempio la
natura gestisce questo fatto della
ricaduta piroclastica e vediamo che per
esempio le piante e non sembra non
soffrire più di tanto soprattutto a
lungo andare questo materiale è
estremamente ricco minerali e nutrienti
per le piante quindi un fertilizzante
potentissimo ed abbiamo potuto vedere in
questa estate con la fioritura prima in
primavera c'erano ferro da poi c'era la
ginestra dell'etna c'era il castagno
dell'eta una fioritura eccezionale e
sicuramente l'ha aiutato tantissimo
anche questo nuovo arrivo di tanta di
questa roba piroclastica però forse
letta ci vuole dire ancora altro letta
sicuramente si fa sentire si farà
sentire sempre per insegnarci certe cose
ci domanda nonostante i problemi che ci
causa di fare attenzione si fa notare è
quasi come ci vuole sentire sveglia
prendete coscienza
prendete coscienza di dove vivete e
perché ci vivete e su che cosa vivete
cominciate ad apprezzare cominciate a
tirare vantaggio di quello che vi do io
perché sì ogni tanto vi do qualche
schiaffo però vito anche tante altre
cose vito l'occasione di riflettere
vidor l'occasione di apprezzare quello
che vi ho creato che vi sto dando per
esempio questo terreno quassù danni sul
quale è stato costruito la città di
catania non ci sarebbe senza le assenze
da senza le colate di lava sono entrate
nel mare una dopo l'altra per creare
questo terreno sul quale è stato
largamente costruita la città di catania
e poi non esisterebbe tutto questo mondo
della montagna
un universo anzi tanti piccoli universi
messi insieme con tante di specie di
piante unica al mondo e quindi questa è
l'occasione di ricordarci e prendere
veramente coscienza che qua viviamo in
un posto straordinario e viviamo su un
vulcano eccezionale che io chiamerei
addirittura non solo il vulcano più
affascinanti al mondo ma anche quello
assolutamente più bello e ora vedrete
perché
mettiamoci sentiamoci un po diamo adesso
la voce quella vera
e grazie ancora